okay so last time we talked about the
Golden Globes you told us you had a
little bit of a wardrobe malfunction B's
sewing back into your dress correct so
is this why we took it easy tonight and
I mean you look fabulous but is this why
we get easy missus Rosetta Getty she's
one of my best friend she's my best
friend since I was we were seven and
eight and she's a big designer now which
is crazy cuz we were like some poor kids
hanging out but we've both done very
well it's very chic and fly and the cut
is impeccable it's also kind of Sheila E
1980s ninety nine point right so that
mean yeah welcome to the the past well
welcome to the party by the way yes
indeed why it's not like you haven't
been here before you're it's still ride
to be invited to the party it's still
amazing I was just telling somebody
earlier you know they think you always
get you know offered everything but
really Sharon bialy who was our casting
director really popped for me for this
part really you know there were people
like no no no no and she was she got a
hold of some footage or something from
escape of ten amaura and convinced them
she really fought for me and that's
something I'm really thinking a lot
about tonight is the relationships
between a casting director and actors
you know they often are your real
champion the interesting thing with you
saying that is I think because your
stature in Hollywood and because you're
one of the best to do it especially from
our generation that anyone would have to
fight for you for a role even kind of
blows my mind it happens all the time
and right now I've taken a year off I've
been promoting those other projects and
I'm gonna do a comedy with Ben Stiller's
directing with Adam Scott but I'm doing
a supporting role so I'm gonna be in
this position again I've been playing
this game for so long that I know I'm
gonna have to fight for my own voice
again in this cuz that's how it works
listen one of the things I love about
you is you know your voice and you sure
aren't afraid to use it and that we
could use that a little bit more in this
day and age
for sure but sure okay so we saw miss
Joey yesterday she's healed
she's good until I get a hold of her
tonight how do we protect Joey tonight
do we put her in a bubble the girl in
the plastic bubble you know if you look
at the footage I'm just you know come on
let's be honest the footage is half me
moving my wart and half her head bunny
and so I don't know what is going on but
I'll tell you tonight
if there's a weapon nearby I will give
that girl a little corn I got out of
that I want to party with Patricia
that's what I want
[Music]